[Musique]
et la vision que ma musique essaie de
représenter celle qui voudrait que on
peut s'imaginer un futur basé sur les
valeurs en ce sera l'africaine
[Musique]
comment tu trouves la réunion
je suis en amour c'est la folie j'ai
rarement vu
de me renseigner si ça coûte pas cher de
d'avoir un petit un petit espace sinon
vraiment c'est tellement beau est-ce que
j'aime aussi c'est le c'est ce métissage
de monde qui rejoint aussi cette vision
futuristique à voir que l'humanité sera
tellement mélangée qu'on aura donné
d'importance à une peau de couleur
que les cultures vont se brasser
justement mon prochain album s'appelle
future Tribe
cette tribu que j'imagine dans le futur
qui dépasse
transversale Universal et de langue
[Musique]